since the Industrial Revolution we've
been increasing co2 concentrations in
the atmosphere faster than at any other
time in the Earth's history in 1750
before the Industrial Revolution every
million molecules in the Earth's
atmosphere contained 280 molecules of
co2 while today in 2015 every million
molecules in the atmosphere contains 400
co2 molecules now that might not seem
like a hugely significant increase but
compare that to the past four hundred
thousand years of co2 concentrations in
the atmosphere so the two concentrations
effectively determine how much energy
the earth radiates out into space and so
determines its temperature it's been
estimated that humans have warmed the
global climate by approximately not 0.8
degrees Celsius since the Year 1880
which is a reasonable benchmark for how
much we've all the climate since the
Industrial Revolution now that's the
warming to date warming in the future is
much more uncertain much of the effect
that we will have on the climate in the
future will come down to how much carbon
we put into the Earth's atmosphere and
the Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change or IPCC have considered multiple
scenarios of emissions and in some cases
mitigation by the world and try to
determine what the effect will be the
21st century will see between naught
point 3 and 1.7 degrees Celsius of
additional warming in the best-case
scenario where the world reduces
emissions as the century goes on and
extensively mitigates its carbon impact
in the worst-case scenario where we
continue to emit as we currently are and
increases emissions every year we expect
the global average change in temperature
to be between two point six and four
point eight degrees Celsius that's a
global average some areas will see
significantly more warming even than
that the effects of this warming are
called climate change and encapsulate
melting ice caps rising sea levels
increases in extreme weather events and
massive population movements I asked my
supervisor here at the University of
Exeter what he expected the long-term
effects of climate change to be unless a
miracle occurs a thousand years from now
all the ecosystems we know today will
destroy there may be some residual
animals living in zoos to kept alive but
like across Africa all the savanna with
the elephants are gone
eventually the ice caps melt like
Florida is a couple little islands left
all the plants and animals are used to
very slow change in the environment and
it would be a very rapid change but ever
wrap it won't be so rapid that within a
given lifetime it looks like a huge
difference like from the time you're
born a time to die
oh maybe snowstorms are less frequent
than when you were a kid it won't be
that noticeable but you added up over
five hundred years or a thousand years
and it's gotta stop it this video is an
excerpt from my crash course on
atmospheric physics if you'd like to
learn more about global warming there's
an entire episode on the subject which
is linked to on the screen and also on
the screen is a link to the series
playlist which covers topics as diverse
as thermodynamics the dynamics of the
stratosphere and what I researched my
PhD thank you very much for watching